bei mir im studio jetzt unser bild
bundeswehr experte maximilian kiewel und
general als doktor stephan chips sowie
professor dr patrick sensburg präsident
des reservistenverbandes vielen dank
dass sie alle da sind
der französische präsident marco hat von
krieg gesprochen wenn es um diese corona
krise geht und unsere deutsche
verteidigungsministerium schrieb heute
morgen in ihren tagesbefehl wir kämpfen
gegen einen unsichtbaren gegner
was meinen sie sind wir wirklich im
krieg im krieg gegen das virus sind wir
schon sieht man ja an sich wenn man
durch berlin fährt das doch die straßen
auch entsprechend leer sind und unser
ganzes leben anfangen vom hände
desinfizieren und so hat sich komplett
geändert also wir sind schon in einem
kampf also krieg ist immer so
martialisch
sie waren 2009 auch in kundus wo
soldaten gefallen sind
jetzt hören wir aus italien das die
triage angewendet werden muss also
müssen ärzte entscheiden sich dafür
entscheiden jüngere menschen erst zu
versorgen muss entscheidungen treffen
bei wem die überlebenschancen höher sind
was denken sie wenn sie das hören und
ist dass auch hier in deutschland
möglich dass ärzte bald die trias
anwenden müssen
ja also erstens ist das für ein arzt
immer die schwerste entscheidung wieder
treffen muss die versuchen wir nach
allem menschlichen ermessen zu vermeiden
aber in dem fall wo ihm die
möglichkeiten eingeschränkt sind und die
anzahl der verletzten oder zubehör ist
dann muss man solche entscheidungen
treffen
das muss man übrigens auch schon wenn
ein bus verunglückt und man an der
unfallstelle ist und die nimmt das sind
sachen die die will man vermeiden aber
wenn wenn es zu der situation kommt dann
muss man dann auch entsprechend
entscheidungen treffen ja das sind die
selektions maßnahmen wie man sie eben
zum beispiel aus dem krieg kennt ja da
haben sie ein lazarett ein krankenhaus
da kommen nach einem anschlag zwei tote
30 verletzte reihen sie müssen
entscheiden der hat die größte chance zu
überleben der ist jugend der blutet
nicht so stark den retten wir der andere
dir müssen wir ein bisschen hinten
anstellen
glauben sie dass das die deutsche
medizin dass deutsche ärzte dafür das
mindset haben darauf vorbereitet sind so
die die sind entsprechend ausgebildet
insbesondere
in den notfall medizin tätig sind die
die machen solche sachen gar nicht so
selten ja so dass man sagt das ist
unsere aufgabe
aber nochmal gesagt wir tun alles um
solche situationen zu vermeiden durch
die kapazitäten im einsatzgebiet also
auch hier zieht kapazitäten die wir
jetzt verhalten kind ganz genau jetzt in
deutschland was tun ihre sanitäter und
ärzte im kampf gegen korona hier in
deutschland momentan wir bereiten uns
also vor auf einen deutlichen anstieg
der infizierten und auch dann der der
erkrankten und treffen die maßnahmen
dass wir eben einem im schulterschluss
mit dem zivilen gesundheitswesen dass
wir da entsprechende voraussetzungen
schaffen also wir haben kapazitäten der
schulen leute die nicht mehr so ganz
aktuell
medizinisch tätig sind und bringen sie
einen schaffen reserven durch mit der
mit der reserve bringen leute aus
unserem regimentern in die krankenhäuser
hinein aber alles im konzert wir sind
teil der gesundheitsversorgung dieser
bundesrepublik deutschland und verstehen
uns auch so in berlin ist ein massen
krankenhaus geplant haben sie dort einen
aktuellen stand wie es ja um dieses
projekt steht
sie könne zu solchen sachen immer sagen
wir haben 1100 krankenhäuser in
deutschland
die ärzte sind da aufgehoben wo sie sich
am besten auswirken können das ist
normal in einem normalen infrastruktur
wenn man anfängt behält infrastruktur zu
bauen
dann zieht man aus der regulär und
struktur menschen in diese welt
strukturen die werden da nicht so wirken
können wie in ihren eigenen
krankenhäusern und deswegen sind wir der
meinung dass das nicht hilfreich ist das
heißt wir sehen dieses krankenhaus
projekt in den messehallen eher kritisch
als ja ich sehe das eher kritisch weil
sie müssen ist damit menschen betreiben
und diese menschen werden aus dem
bisherigen gesundheitssystem
herausgezogen und müssen dann in den
messehallen arbeiten da ist die frage
wie man da sich vorstellt wieder
intensiv patienten behandelt werden
sollen also ich würde sagen da wo man
ist in der scheide im
bundeswehrkrankenhaus in berlin
da wirken sich die ärzte am besten aus
da fragen wir die kapazitäten hoch und
das ist das was wir machen sollten ja
und nicht von vornherein elf wels
infrastrukturen
wir haben gehört es gibt
amtshilfegesuche aus halle große stadt
aus heinsberg können sie da sagen was
die bundeswehr was ihre kameraden
momentan leisten und tun
also wir wir sind natürlich jederzeit
bereit zu unterstützen aber unsere
hauptaufgabe ist und das muss man
einfach immer wieder sagen wir sind
integraler bestandteil dieses zivil und
gesundheitswesen wir machen da voll mit
wir fahren hoch wir haben auch keine
überschüssigen reserven die wir dort zur
verfügung stellen können
sondern wenn dann einzelne kleinere
gebinde von uns verlangt werden zehn
mann zum fiebermessen oder in nrw
ambulanz natürlich helfen
aus mit unseren strukturen aber unser
hauptziel ist unser eigenes system
hochzufahren damit war im konzert mit
den anderen krankenhäusern am ort
regional für die bevölkerung zur
verfügung stehen ist auch denkbar dass
ihre ärzte in zivile krankenhäuser gehen
und dort mitarbeiter selbstverständlich
ist alles denkbar wenn not am mann ist
aber wie gesagt wir wir stellen unsere
kapazitäten bereit und werden natürlich
in einem einzelfall auch unterstützen
können aber es gibt nicht die und wir
wir sind eins gesamtstaatliche aufgabe
und die bundeswehr ist da mittendrin
herr dr salzburg von ihren reservisten
kamen in diesen tagen eine der wenigen
nachrichten die wirklich mut gemacht hat
sie haben einen freiwilligen aufruf
gestartet an die reservisten und
vielleicht kann sie einmal erzählen was
ist was ist dann passiert werden das
gemeinsam mit der bundeswehr natürlich
gemacht und wir haben gesagt wer in der
sanität ausgebildet ist der soll sich
melden
da haben wir bedarf auch dann in
entsprechende stellen zu gehen zu
unterstützen
das haben sich ein sehr kurzer zeit bis
zum heutigen tag rund 2000 personen
gemeldet von denen fast die hälfte
wirklich auch in den funktionen
gebraucht werden kann da schauen wir
jetzt wo können sie unterstützen
ein hohes engagement das engagement geht
auch weit darüber hinaus auch
soldatinnen und soldaten der reserve
melden sich wie nichts an die täter sind
diese aber sagen wir können vielleicht
im bereich logistik wir können im
bereich der unterstützungsleistungen für
lkw fahrer an der autobahn mithelfen mit
anpacken oder wir können in den
einheiten überall wo sie gebraucht
werden unterstützen und das ist wirklich
toll dass so viele reservistinnen und
reservisten sich melden und sagen wir
wollen mit anpacken im sinne von tu was
für deutschland lassen die in dem moment
an ihren beruf ruhen gerade oder was was
wie läuft der alltag bei denen ab das
ist ganz unterschiedlich in welcher
lebenslage sich befinden dabei sind es
selbstständige die zurzeit nicht so viel
zu tun haben weil sind es betriebe die
sagen wir haben keinen bedarf geht nach
hause das muss man dann mit dem
arbeitgeber natürlich abklären
also ganz unterschiedliche lebenslagen
in denen sich die reservistinnen und
reservisten befinden
und sie klären das für sich ab und sagen
ich könnte und dann muss im einzelfall
geprüft werden wo können sie eingesetzt
werden wo gibt es bedarf da wird
vielleicht nicht jeder eingesetzt werden
können aber eben ganz unterschiedlich
brauchen wir reservisten und reservisten
denn um die struktur eben aufzufüllen
verkehrsminister scheuer hat erwähnt
dass die bundeswehr auch bei der
logistik wenn
zum versorgung geht helfen kann wie
sehen sie beide das hat die bundeswehr
da kapitän für kann sie dabei helfen die
versorgung in ganz deutschland jetzt
sicher zu stellen
ja ich denke dass eines der der punkte
wenn wir die möglichkeit nahmen dann
machen wir das natürlich für uns
sanitätsdienst steht das nicht im fokus
das machen die die die amtshilfe dann
auch bearbeiten und wir haben natürlich
kräfte die sowas machen können und was
mich da sehr freut ist ja dass man in so
krise lang dann immer sehr schnell an
die bundeswehr denkt wenn das außerhalb
von krisenlagen also wäre dann wäre ich
auch sehr danke da gibt es möglichkeiten
auch bei reservistinnen und reservisten
wir sehen ja gerade dass viele von
früher noch ein lkw führerschein haben
und wir leben in deutschland dass wir
gar nicht zu wenig waren haben und güter
haben sie teilweise aber von den großen
logistikzentren nicht in die fläche
gebracht werden können
und da überlegen wir schauen ob wir
unterstützend tätig werden können wenn
bedarf ist dann muss das angemeldet
werden und ich glaube auch da gibt es
die möglichkeit für reservistinnen und
reservisten zu unterstützen ich würde ja
noch einmal auf eine rechtliche und auch
sicherlich emotionale thematik zu
sprechen kommen wir sehen in italien in
frankreich ausgangssperren und dort
steht eben auf der straße neben der
polizei auch das militär die diese
ausgangssperren überwachen ist das etwas
was in deutschland so auch denkbar wäre
dass die bundeswehr auf der straße steht
und ausgangssperren überwacht leute
zurück in ihre häuser schickt also ich
sehe dass derzeit nicht die ministerin
hat es in der pressekonferenz relativ
deutlich gemacht die sicherung im
inneren ist aufgabe der polizei der
ordnungsbehörden der kommunen nicht der
bundeswehr
ich könnte mir stattdessen vorstellen
dass die bundeswehr in manchen bereichen
zum beispiel zum objektsicherung geht
die polizei entlastet wenn wir also eine
kritische infrastruktur denken da haben
wir private sicherungs dienste da haben
wir auch teilweise die polizei die jetzt
ganz andere aufgaben haben
da können wir unterstützen wenn es die
länder anfordern im bereich der inneren
sicherheit haben wir klassische aufgaben
die durch die polizei die ordnungsämter
abgedeckt werden dafür sind sie auch
ausgebildet und das können sie auch und
wir können in den bereichen wo sie dann
fehlen aufgaben übernehmen eine letzte
frage noch dazu das heißt es könnte sein
dass wir ein bild haben in deutschland
wo bewaffnete deutsche soldaten wider
vor zum beispiel kraftwerken stehen und
diese absichern
ja es kann sein dass objektschutz durch
die bundeswehr vorgenommen wird
dementsprechend sind die soldatinnen und
soldaten dann natürlich ausgerüstet das
muss mit den ländern abgeklärt werden da
wo bedarf ist aber das wäre eine
möglichkeit wo die bundeswehr
unterstützen kann
im inland aufgaben der polizei zu
übernehmen sehe ich derzeit keinen
bedarf sehe ich nicht gleiche
ausbildungsgänge und ich sehe auch
derzeit nicht dass die polizei das nicht
machen kann
sie ist gut ausgebildet wir haben gut
trainierte polizistinnen und polizisten
ich glaube dass diese aufgaben auch von
ihnen wahrgenommen werden